[Music]
basically what happened to me this
weekend you know i did all that
cart driving and then i was like i'm
just ran a porsche just to see what it's
like
oh yeah you rented a porsche just give
it a shot
where are you yeah people are like did
you buy that thing
i'm like i'm not gonna say [ __ ] and just
let people let the hate build
wait did you throw it up on your story
yeah just a little
like a little like emblem on the
steering wheel nah i just like took a
shot at like the hood
and i put a little emoji like oh yeah
yeah i did see that
it was sick i had you know i just had to
i had to
hey yeah ambiguous flex
[Laughter]
could be rented it it could not could be
in a parking lot somewhere
it could be entirely something it could
be someone else's i could have snuck in
somewhere
that's the best kind of flex like when
people when you go to a person's page
and they're constantly taking pictures
next to
nice cars but they're always different
it's like you definitely don't
like these are other people's cars how
is this a flex
yeah i'm gonna start once once i get the
vaccine i'm gonna start that's
my first thing on instagram i'm going to
go around
out strictly just take pictures with
other people's cars
and i'm just like oh this is some dude's
car
this is some other dude's car hey excuse
me they're like wait are you that guy
from tick tock
oh no i just wondering if you can take a
picture with this car it's sick
i don't give a [ __ ] what you doing
actually i don't care at all
do you mind rolling up her window so
people think it's mine thanks bro
uh i really don't like those videos
excuse me
nice car what do you do for a living it
just seems like they're all staged now
yeah they all are for the most part you
know you get the random guys that are
like i'm a
airline pilot and you're like
really rolls royce
[Laughter]
hey bro there's a you'd be surprised if
you get through an auction i forgot what
site it is but
shout out to ben he sent me this auction
site
it was crazy the kind of cars you could
get on there and for the prices
sweet but yeah um you know what you know
what
you know like this this uh weight roll
for cars and g wagons have you seen this
no there's a tick tock that went viral
i've seen it like a few times people
like these finance guys will be like do
you know why so many business owners
have g wagons well let me tell you
it's some like weight rule for taxes for
businesses so i think it's meant for
people that are supposed to
or that are buying like freight vans and
semi-trucks and [ __ ] like that
but if your car is over a certain weight
limit you can write off a lot of it
on your taxes so a g wagon is over that
weight limit
and chewing
so g-wagon is like 140k or whatever and
you can write off
40k of it and as long as you sell it in
three years that's part of the rule for
some reason
you better sell it in three it usually
decreases about 40k in value during that
time so you can essentially just drive a
g-wagon for free
for three years i guess that's the hack
ah
that's cool i guess oh i don't know i
think it's kind of cool i'll tell you
just don't know how you
know that [ __ ] you know i don't know
like
who i mean yeah who's researching these
things
that's like um i think that's when
you're just obsessed with money saving
money
you know that's when like money is like
literally all you think about
you know like you're sitting there
reading
you know french tax board [ __ ] and
you're like what what
could i what could i scheme on this year
yeah you know yeah what can i get my
little fingers into you know a little
loop
okay yeah i gotta hold my finger hey
yeah
it's taking your your rich little
fingers just trying to
yeah what kind of i don't know
oh found some
babe if we both ride a motorcycle at the
same time it's free
for the first six months so we buy
harley davidson then return it
on or sell it on five months and
29 days huh yeah yes and then they
then they take a bunch of pictures with
it make content out of it and they make
ad revenue and then it's like what's
going on
over there he's he's like being
so weird today barking at everything
does ollie ever get like that like
random days where he's just testy
um yeah yeah the thing that
i had seen was when dogs do that
you like you go out to them you're like
hey and then you calm them down first
and then you let them return to their
routine
so you have to show them that they're
barking at nothing or something
i don't know okay so you don't just i'll
tell you this dude
yeah that doesn't work you're saying
yeah it increases the trauma i think
gotcha gotcha okay it makes them more on
edge
hey hey hey hey
then you're both just screaming hey at
each other he said dog is audible but
it's not super distracting okay okay
that's fine
um yeah i'll tell you when you get a
porsche you're like in the
you're in like the the cool cool kids
club like
i drove that [ __ ] around and you know
you realize how many people drive
porsches and
every single one that would drive past
me was like [ __ ]
yeah that's us man
yeah i was like for sure
that's what's up yeah no they're all
like
they're all like 35 year old dudes
with like f1 hats like f1 racing team
hats
okay um you know like some guy pulled up
next to me in a
like a 911 uh gts or something
he rolls down his window and he's like
what's up man i'm like hey
and elena looks at me she's like why the
[ __ ] did he just do that
it's just dude i'm like flirting man
dude yeah i'm like it's it it's the
sick color yeah the color is like
talking about me or the
car this is tender for guys after
marriage
like this is what it is yeah gt4 coming
down the street i'm gonna give it a shot
like no you're not yeah i am full
head's that one
love it man i would have got it myself
oh nice dude
we should totally cruise together yeah
yeah we're doing a show
we're actually we're all gonna park in
the gelsons parking lot
it's kind of just vibe you down 6 00 a.m
yeah i'd love to yeah yeah yeah i drove
by
the gelsons park there's a real story i
drove by at 6am there was like 6000 bmws
there and all these dudes outside like
like i'm standing right now just looking
over
damn yeah she's a beaut man what do you
got going on this thing what's the
engine what's the run train like what's
the big
you know big shifter lack because you
know what's gonna happen
right at you know right at 6 30 they're
all gonna get on the road
they're gonna go up to some canyon and
just terrorize it as a as a mob
it's all just
two hours malibu residents being like
shut the [ __ ] up what is that
no yeah trying to sleep god dammit
dude i [ __ ] man
we should meet up in the gelson's
parking lot to like for other things
not just it doesn't have to be cars yeah
it could be um
pottery people what else are dudes into
trains
like train sets damn right
what else are guys into trains
guys love running train
i meant i made something much less cool
than that oh it's just
like toy trains like lionel train model
trains
yeah yeah um what else
fishing gear yeah woodworking
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna meet up in
the ralph's parking lot and
uh show each other our band saws vacuum
collectors you know
this is my hoover 11 9xl
nice model they discontinued that one
didn't they yeah vintage uh this is one
of the
original actually four model displays
from
vacuum world 1967 so
yeah bro about after after having that
experience it made me want one
for real so i get it
i get it so you're gonna cough i mean
i don't know that's like that's
uh there's a reason guys buy that [ __ ]
like way late in life
i don't think that car is very practical
it's
so [ __ ] low to the ground it's like
it's a literal race car
every every regular thing became so
difficult
we we went to go get coffee somewhere
or alina wanted some and uh just
i couldn't get into the parking lot i
was like yeah driveway rake's too high
and i just park it and walk up to get
the and like this la it's going to be
like that everywhere so
yeah yeah that's why we can't go sorry
that's why dudes go to the gelsons at
6am and they put it out in the lot and
they're like
yeah i haven't been able to drive this
thing for a month and i just yeah
they're all just impressed that they got
in the gelson's video yeah they're like
the [ __ ] you get that thing in here man
i wanted to park here forever never had
the balls
yeah and there's like there's a ton more
just driving by like i wanna go in there
man like just [ __ ] man that looks so
sick
i would love to park in a gel since dude
i would [ __ ] love it you know what
i'm gonna do a u-turn drive-by one more
time just trying to like muster the
carriage and maybe do it
no no no i can't i can't no no you gotta
do it that's why they gotta get there at
5 00 a.m so there's no traffic so they
can really
have the time to get the car up the
[ __ ]
driveway yeah yeah
that was um when i took it out of the
lot to rent
it i knew i was going to scrape the
front lip and
the sound that [ __ ] makes and especially
when it's not your car it's like
just closing my eyes at one mile an hour
just please please please
don't was it expensive to rent no it was
like 300 bucks
a what for a day for a day oh my god
that's sick
how to do it how to do it yeah that's an
e that's a no
brain ski i might do that when i get
when i get back but something like a
delorean or something you know
yeah i mean like the ferraris and stuff
they're way more expensive they're like
800
000 a day so i thought that's like a
dope in between
also i took that thing through two
canyons
and um for what like little moments i
got to like push it
i had myself a little uh race car boy
nut
nice this car is sick yeah yeah
that's why i did doing the same thing on
the bike honestly
you